today on the matt wall show the left
screeches in horror as elon musk
launches his hostile takeover of twitter
threatening to allow the open exchange
of ideas the horror also the suspect in
the new york city subway mass shooting
has an extensive criminal history and
yet was allowed to remain on the street
until now that's what criminal justice
reform gets you plus kentucky
effectively outlaws abortion nfts are
once again revealed to be a ridiculous
scam and the ladies of the view descend
into hilarious incoherence while
attempting to discuss gay marriage talk
about all that and much more today on
the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
have you thought about buying a new home
maybe a second home or an investment
property it really is the perfect time
to do so home values are up over 20 last
year that's quite the return if you ask
me that's why i recommend calling
american financing america's home for
home loans they're a family-owned
company and a proud partner of the matt
wall show they'll work with you guide
you through custom loan options and walk
you through every step of the process it
really is a no pressure experience with
them and they never charge upfront or
hidden fees which is quite refreshing
since many lenders charge 500 or so just
to get you qualified don't do that
instead give american financing a call
and get a free loan review and even be
connected to a realtor if you need one
it takes as little as 10 minutes it's
very easy to do very simple all you have
to do is start by calling 866-569-4711
again that's 866-569-4711
one more time that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls
182-334-nmlsconsumeraccess.org
well i may not seem to be the biggest
champion of diversity but i can still
appreciate watching a glass ceiling get
shattered as much as any progressive the
truth is that despite appearances you
know i do deeply value diversity equity
inclusion tolerance
i know that this country has come so far
in atoning for the sins of its past and
yet it still has so much farther to go
and that's why i nearly wept with tears
of joy this morning as i heard the news
that an african-american man may soon
take ownership of twitter we we inched
ever closer to true and complete racial
equity in this country when elon musk
positioned himself to potentially become
the first african-american immigrant to
own a major social media platform this
is this is big news big progress kataji
brown jackson's confirmation
may have been an historic achievement
but it pales in comparison to this
as the daily wire reports elon musk the
tech billionaire who made waves across
the world after recently becoming the
largest twitter shareholder is offering
to buy 100 of twitter at 54.20
per share in a cash deal that could
exceed 40 billion dollars according to
an sec filing submitted wednesday
evening musk told twitter chairman brett
taylor that this was his best and final
offer the offer comes just days after
musk declined to take a position on
twitter's board of directors
and now we know why he declined to take
that position
you can read in the sec filing the voice
and text message from musk to twitter
where he explains his offer he
emphasizes again that he's not going to
negotiate it's his best and final
but if the board doesn't accept the
offer which i don't know how they could
choose not to accept as declining the
offer would be them acting against the
financial interests of their
shareholders
but if they don't accept musk indicated
that he would reconsider quote-unquote
his position as a shareholder
so this is in other words a hostile
takeover and certainly if they refuse
the offer and musk pulls out completely
twitter's stock price is going to
plummet through the floor
so they're backed into a corner it would
seem and it is a glorious site to behold
now as for the reaction to this news it
has been as you might expect
quite dramatic
some of us though see this as you know
not only a major win for racial equity
but also an opportunity for example i've
already reached out to elon on twitter
and offered my services as the company's
new chief diversity and inclusion
officer i assume there's going to be a
lot of vacancies coming up especially in
those kinds of departments and i am
willing to do that i don't even need a
seven figure income to do the job i'd
settle for something even in just like
the high six figure range
but the left has not been quite so
hopeful or optimistic they are treating
this like the end of the world literally
i mean somebody tweeted this morning
quote elon musk buying twitter is the
end of the world basically he'll amplify
every extremist right-wing nazi he can
find
the verified left-wing blue checks on
the platform especially are having a
difficult time we're going to read some
of these and i think we might need some
sad piano music again for this
lance richardson says
elon musk buying twitter if he's indeed
successful might be the impetus i've
been looking for to delete this thing
permanently
there's a lot of that by the way people
threatening to leave leftist threatening
to leave
it's like one of those is that a a
threat or a promise kind of thing
max boot says
i'm frightened by the impact on society
and politics if elon musk acquires
twitter he seems to believe that on
social media anything goes
for democracy to survive we need more
content moderation not less
just stop and think about that for a
second for democracy to survive we need
more content moderation
for democracy to survive there needs to
be less ability to express
your point of view
makes sense whitney don carlson says
more simply f you elon musk
and then miguel an employee of twitter
says
i can't even with elon buying twitter i
may have to rethink my employment if
that actually happens
and pam keith says i love you all but i
am 100
out if musk takes over twitter no pam
keith keith don't leave please we beg
you to stay
well you know what actually call this
whole thing off i just decided i thought
it was good but if pam keith
is not going to be on twitter with elon
musk in control then forget the whole
thing it's not worth it
um matthew rosa desperately beseeched
the current ceo of twitter to resist the
takeover attempt he tweeted dear parag
agrawal if you're reading this right now
the world needs to know that you're
stronger smarter and more tenacious than
elon musk
he thinks he can beat you
the free world needs to know that he's
wrong
yours truly a lifelong and long verified
twitter user
that's also how that's how i sign all of
my letters as well actually as it
happens um don't ask either of us how we
could possibly be lifelong twitter users
that's it that's irrelevant
and then finally of course jeff jarvis
pushes the nazi button in case of
emergency push the nazi button which
it's like it's always an emergency for
the left so
he says today on twitter feels like the
last evening in a berlin nightclub at
the twilight of weimer germany
[Music]
yes
the prospect that people expressing
their of people expressing their
opinions honestly on twitter
is exactly like
nazi germany
people being able to tweet
memes with abandon
it's just like nazism there's no
difference really
now
jokes somewhat aside
i think i do think there are two
important points to be made about this
um aside from the fact that elon musk is
an african-american man which by the way
like that will never not be hilarious to
say i don't care how many times the joke
is used it's not even really jokes
that's technically true
it that's just the gr that's one of my
favorite honestly one of my favorite
facts
in the universe actually is that elon
musk is an african-american because they
hate him so much and he's like the
richest guy in the world and he's and it
makes them so mad when you call him an
african-american but they can't it's
true so they can't do anything about it
i just i love it anyway um
so the first thing to keep in mind here
is that as happy as i am about elon musk
potentially seizing the reins at twitter
and as delighted as i am to drink from
such an abundance of leftist tears so
many tears that my my tumbler can can't
possibly hold them all
i do however think that we should
acknowledge that it's not a good sign
that we're relying on the benevolence of
an eccentric billionaire to protect the
free exchange of ideas
you know if you had any doubt before
this is now all the confirmation you
should need that we we do live in an
oligarchy ours is a country fully in the
hands of a group of elites in government
media in the corporate world pushing and
pulling and conspiring with each other
and sometimes fighting with each other
to control our lives
that's that's the world we live in it's
not a good system
but since we're stuck in it for now the
best thing that can happen within the
system is that at least one of these
powerful people decides that free speech
is actually important and seizes control
of a platform like twitter to provide a
forum for it
second we have to ask
why exactly is the left panicking so
much at the thought of elon musk taking
control of twitter
um the answer is obvious but worth
articulating in any case
musk is not despite how he's portrayed
some sort of right-wing ideologue
he's not going to go in and start
banishing all the leftist accounts out
into the hinterlands as satisfying as
that might be to see
from a retribution kind of perspective
but he's not going to do that and
everyone knows he's not going to do that
the fear on the left is
not that they'll be banished
but that musk will make good on his
promise to allow the free and open
expression of opinions and ideas
leftism's cultural dominance relies
heavily
almost entirely on the control of
expression
it hasn't taken this position of
dominance by
defeating the other side in the
ideological arena it hasn't convinced
people to come over to its camp it
hasn't made like convincing arguments
and people say oh wow you know i've
considered both points of view and sure
it's ideas cannot prevail in that kind
of contest
they don't stand up against even the
slightest scrutiny
so for leftism the game is won by making
sure that it is the only team allowed on
the field
this kind of suppression accomplishes i
think two things for them one
it of course ensures that people don't
encounter the opposing views or hear the
arguments and because you don't need to
bother debunking or defeating arguments
that nobody hears anyway
very often people come up to me
and uh they'll like thank me for making
some point or another and and then
they'll tell me that oh you know i'd
never heard that before i've never heard
anyone put it like that before and
that's always shocking to me because all
i ever do
is state the obvious i i have no deeper
insights to offer really and yet
um
and don't quote me on that you know
because you're still watching the show
but really what i'm doing is just
stating the obvious and yet even obvious
truths are kept out of view
from so many people
the other thing that suppression
accomplishes i think even more so is
isolation
this is another thing that i hear all
the time for people because if it's
common sense it means that it's a lot of
these things are the kinds of things
people know you don't need to tell them
they just know it
like that you know men and women are
different for example it's a common
sense thing it's self-evident
maybe one of the most self-evident facts
in the world
and so everyone kind of knows they don't
need to tell them that
and yet the other thing that i get from
people they'll come and they'll thank me
for expressing some opinion
uh or another because prior to hearing
me say it they thought that they were
alone in thinking that way
or nearly alone and this is always
surprising too because again you know
it's it's common sense but leftist
speech suppression has made it so that
people with normal common sense ideas
about the world
feel like they are alone
and after a while if you think you're
alone
in feeling a certain way or thinking a
certain way or having a certain opinion
you might surrender to the mainstream
view just for the sake of
self-preservation
or you might convince yourself that you
must be wrong
given that you're so outnumbered
this is the process that's actually
happened with some people on the gender
issue
and a lot some sometimes it also is
dependent some in some ways on on where
you live
um
but
people are so surrounded by this
insanity that after a while they start
to think well am i am i wrong about this
i thought men and women are different
but everywhere i go and
everyone seems to be affirming the
opposite
so this is a very valuable tool to the
left
and it's what they stand to lose
at least partially if twitter slips out
of their hands and it's why they're
panicking
and it's why it's so enjoyable to behold
and besides if you're on the left and
you're worried about this
what's the big deal remember what you
always told us
just go build your own twitter
it's not hard to do
so good luck
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know if your retirement account has
been heavy on stocks for a while i have
some great news for you you've won the
value of your ira or 401k has likely
ballooned thanks to the longest bull
market run in u.s history but after
every bull run comes a recession right
now stock valuations are at historic
highs only seen before the great
depression and the dot-com crash in the
face of teetering global global
stability stock volatility is way up so
maybe it's time to take some of your
chips off the table secure your winnings
and your future with gold from birch
gold that's right birch gold will help
you convert those gains that you have on
paper into a real physical asset oh yeah
and it will still be a tax sheltered
account for the best parts nice try
uncle sam especially as we get to tax
season now get started now text walsh to
98 98 98 with thousands of satisfied
customers in an a plus rating with the
better business bureau birch gold can
help you protect your savings all you've
got to do is text walsh to 98 98 98 to
get a free info kit on gold there is no
obligation to get this info text walsh
to 98 98 98 to protect at least some of
your winnings with gold
all right um
you know if you're if a lot of people
there's many different ways to
access this podcast because you know you
have to be it's the modern world you
have to be available through every
platform including like messenger pigeon
and everything else
um a lot of people watch on youtube but
uh probably the main way people engage
with it is the audio podcast and if
you're not subscribed to the audio
podcast then you should definitely do
that you can go to apple podcast spotify
wherever you get your audio podcast make
sure that you not only are listening
there but you also hit that subscribe
button just a reminder for you all right
um
i i want to mention this too because it
kind of relates to what we were just
talking about it very much relates to it
so right before this announcement from
elon musk coming in potentially as the
liberator here um libs of tick tock
was suspended yesterday on twitter and
this is a
a personal tragedy for me
because that's my whole show like the
libsa tiktok account does my entire show
that's all my show prep it's out the
window if i don't have libs of tick and
um but the account was suspended daily
wire reports popular twitter account
libs of tick tock known for exposing
radical gender theories promoted by
school and teachers has been suspended
for twitter by twitter for 12 hours for
violating its rules against hateful
conduct
babylon bceo seth dillon was the first
to report the suspension with a tweet
the vague notice from twitter shared by
dylan's tweet simply states we have
determined that this account violated
the twitter rules specifically for
violating our rules against hateful
conduct
you may not promote violence against
threaten or harass other people on the
basis of race ethnicity national origin
sexual orientation gender gender
identity religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease
but i guess you can discriminate for
non-serious diseases
um
where does where does alopecia fall into
that is that in a serious thing i think
we discovered that last week it's in the
serious in the serious category of
course this doesn't make any sense and
this is exactly the kind of thing this
is they give themselves
these broad kind of meaningless
categories
of speech that they can police hateful
conduct well who decides what's hateful
exactly
yeah they they pretend to define it more
they say well promote violence threaten
harass
what do you mean by harass how do you
define that exactly
and promote violence you might think you
know what a term like promote violence
means you might think that well
promoting violence means that you're
uh telling people to go and commit a
violent act against somebody that's what
promoting violence is in in the brain of
a normal person
but then you remember that the on the
left they have a very expansive idea of
what violence is
and a word can be violent an opinion can
be violent
um you know an expression on your face
can be found
moving your fingers a certain way could
be could be you know doing this you're
not supposed to do this the okay sign
that's violence that's white supremacist
supremacist violence so they give
themselves these um
broad categories so that it's just up to
them who they're going to kick out and
and or suspended
90 of the time what do you know it's a
conservative account
but the limits of tick tock thing is
especially interesting because all this
account does
really all it does
is just repost
um
that's why it's libs of tick tock
content from a lot of times other
platforms and say look at look at what
this person said on tick tock
that's all the account does
so why was it really kicked off because
it was effective
and it was effective just in alerting
people to the full insanity of leftism
maybe that's another thing that uh
you know maybe maybe elon musk will
liberate lives of tick tock donald trump
we'll see
i can tell you one thing
if musk takes control of twitter
i am gonna go on a misgendering spree
i'm gonna be misgendering so hard on
that platform
and of course when i say misgender i
mean
properly and appropriately gender people
according to their biological sex
um
let's see let's uh let's go here from
nbc new york it says the man sought as a
person of interest in the mass shooting
on a brooklyn train during rush hour a
day ago frank james has now been labeled
a suspect in the case
um
james is believed to have been taken
into custody on wednesday according to
four police sources so he graduated from
person of interest to he is the actual
suspect which i think we all knew was
gonna happen and now apparently he's
been apprehended not apparently there's
video footage of him being apprehended
um
three senior law enforcement officials
said atf agents were able to trace the
gun recovered at the shooting scene to a
purchase that james made years ago
um and there was video also video
started coming out of um
james entering the subway now it's kind
of an interesting thing because
there it's the subway in new york and so
you'd think well there's security camera
footage certain security cameras
everywhere
and there is and we saw we saw some
footage of him of him coming in
but apparently right now there is
no footage
available to anyone of the attack itself
despite the fact that there's
uh
cameras everywhere
now listen to this part though
about james it says james has ties to
philadelphia and wisconsin as well as
new york according to police he was said
to have a past criminal record in new
jersey that includes three arrests on
charges related to larceny and
disorderly conduct in 2007 and
trespassing in 1992.
james that's in new jersey
um
james also has nine prior arrests in new
york from 1992 to 1998 including
possession of burglary tools criminal
sex acts and theft of service however he
has no history on par with the violence
he's suspected of in tuesday's attack of
which fish officials are aware at this
time
um part of james's criminal history
includes making terroristic threats
according to sources
but investigators said the threats were
similar to ones commonly made by those
who are emotionally disturbed
okay
so this is someone with an extensive
criminal record
who's who made terroristic threats that
he eventually carried out
he was known to the fbi
we know that he was known to local law
enforcement because he's getting
arrested all the time
known to the fbi
and yet they just let him
let him go let him walk around a free
man until he did something where they
have no choice but to take him into
custody
and man how many how many years is even
gonna get in new york now
will they put them away for at least a
decade can we can we hope for that much
you know we hear about criminal justice
reform
and even a lot of republicans are very
excited about criminal justice reform
well this is what criminal justice
reform gets you this is what it looks
like
it looks like a career criminal
committing crime after crime after crime
and the
law enforcement everybody knows that
he's a criminal a potentially dangerous
person
and yet he is simply allowed to continue
escalating in his crimes until he does
something
so heinous that there is no choice but
to put him away that's what criminal
justice reform is
that's what it is now now
what could it be
well my idea for criminal justice reform
here's here's how we should be reforming
the criminal justice system
here's my idea
uh what you do is you
find the dangerous people
and you put them
in a cage
and you keep them there for a long time
so the kind of criminal justice reform
we need is the opposite of what we're
getting the kind we need is
arrest more people
and keep them in jail
longer i mean this this whole idea that
um
you know over incarceration too many
people are going to jail or arresting
too many people
where's the evidence of that exactly
you can look at the crime wave plaguing
cities all across the country
we can all see that how can you look at
that and see these violent criminals
running amok and then come to the
conclusion that the problem is that
we're still arresting too many people
yeah all of these violent people are on
the streets actually we need more of
them is what we're told by the criminal
justice reform advocates
now arrest more people
and put them in jail for longer if
you've got to build more jails to to
house all the scumbags then build more
of them
i'm willing to pay for that as a
taxpayer
i pay for a lot of stuff that doesn't
benefit me i don't need
well taking the violent people and and
putting them in cages where they belong
and keeping them there that that's
something that will benefit me as as a
member of the community and especially
as a father of young children
all right a similar vein here this is
from wzm in michigan
the grand rapids police department
released video footage of an officer who
shot and killed 26 year old patrick
lyola lyo yeah i believe it is
during a traffic stop that turned deadly
last week
and this was trending yeah last night on
on twitter the the video itself
um the incident happened
monday april 4th just after 8 a.m during
the intersection of grigg street nelson
avenue authorities said a grpd officer
initiated a traffic stop on a vehicle
with a faulty license plate
uh the suspect who was driving the
vehicle
fled from police on foot after a
physical struggle with the officer he
was shot and killed grpd chief eric
winstrom confirmed the officer's body
camera was found at the scene said it
wasn't clear how it came off um
la oya's uh family disputes these claims
saying that his car had broken down in
the street and that he had stepped out
of the car to see what the problem was
when a grpd officer arrived his family
says he and the officer argued then the
officer got a hold of him and put him on
the ground the officer then shot him in
the back of the head the family says the
officer at the center of the
investigation has not been publicly
identified um the officer has been
placed on administrative leave pending
the investigation now the video is out
they're not going to play it for you
here you can go and it's you know it's a
video of someone being shot and killed
and we we've all gotten so used to
watching we talked about this last week
i mean we've gotten so used to watching
videos of people dying and i i don't
think that that's something we should
really be
used to actually um but if you want to
see the video you can it's out there on
twitter
um and it's on social media
now
this there's still as is always the case
with these things
a lot of facts that we don't have yet
and but that doesn't trouble most people
um especially the race hustlers who
they've seen all they need to see
this is a white officer and a black
suspect who ends up dead and for them
that's it that's all that matters
and they've already jumped they've
come to a conclusion
that they will stick with no matter what
else we find out
so we know that's how it works there
but if you actually care about the truth
then you need more information and
that's what we should that's what we
need here
um i will say
i i'm extremely skeptical of the claim
from the family
that his car just broke down and for
some reason the cop came and tackled him
like just for
you know for no reason
um
because
that's always the kind of narrative we
get in the beginning
with these kinds of incidents and it
almost never in fact i think i would say
never stands up against scrutiny
like we're always told in the beginning
that the suspect was doing something
totally you know it was just totally
innocent there was nothing at all just
walking down the street and the cop came
up randomly and that's how the
altercation began
that's always what we're told in the
beginning and then it turns out that no
that's not the case
um what we hear from the police is that
this was a traffic stop
and um
then he took off running and the cop
tried to uh tried to apprehend him
and then that's the part where the video
picks up and you can see
lyola is uh fighting the officers
something happened over the course of
several minutes trying to bring him down
at some point the suspect gains control
you could see in the video he gained he
takes the taser away from the officer
and so now he's armed himself with the
officer's taser
and while he's struggling for the taser
and they're still struggling the
struggling again goes on for for for uh
you know several minutes
um that's when he gets shot
now here's my thing
and again we're going to find out more
information about the shooting what led
to it what precipitated it
all that information will come out
but
here's here's a thought
black lives matter right of course we
all no one disagrees with that
so value your own life
now the the the
patrick lyola
the cops are trying to detain him
he's fighting back he grabs the taser
nothing good
can come of that
there's there's no
good
path that you go there's there's no
positive result from that decision
once the cops are trying to arrest you
you start fighting back nothing good can
possibly come of it
you are now putting yourself in a lethal
situation potentially
and especially if you if you believe
that cops are all a bunch of racist
psychopathic murderers
then even more so right you're putting
yourself in a lethal position
if you actually believe that
that's the other thing that doesn't make
any sense to me is because we hear
um about all the alleged fear of police
because they're all a bunch of of
killers
yet you see in these videos people that
appear that appear to have no fear of
the police whatsoever
like it wouldn't i would it would never
occur to me to fight a police officer
and try to take his taser from him
um i
would fear the police too much to do
something like that
and also more importantly value my own
life
i want to i i love living my life i want
to get home to my kids i'm not going to
do something like
quite with there's no positive result
that's possible here and the potential
negative result is that i die and if i
don't die now i'm just going to go to
prison for longer than i would have
otherwise
especially if you were really doing
nothing wrong whatsoever
and now you're fighting the cops well
now you're gonna go to jail if you don't
do anything wrong then you fight it in
court and there's no reason why you
should go to jail
but now you're gonna go to jail
so why not place some value on your own
life
the first thing that jumps out at me
when i see pretty much all of these
videos the ones that blm you know cherry
picks
and i watch a suspect fighting the cops
going for the weapon doing all this and
i think what why don't you value your
own life
why are you willing to throw your life
away for nothing
what's the plan here
okay you fight the cops
that's first step what's steps two and
three
explain it to me i don't get it
and then what's the other thing you see
um there's always there are the people
standing off filming it
and i don't know in this case the person
who's filming i don't know who they are
know if they're related to the to the
uh
to anybody involved or whatever it's a
friend but you see people standing off
filming it and
it's it's it's not very often that
they're encouraging the person hey man
just just just give up fight this in
court it's not worth your life
said they're just standing off watching
waiting for them to get shot
what's like what so they have the viral
video that they can put on social media
all right uh this is from breitbart
president joe biden's administration is
extending the federal mass mandate for
americans traveling on commercial buses
and flights while carrying out plans to
end chinese chronovirus restrictions for
border crossers and illegal aliens
so if you're crossing the border
illegally then uh you don't have the
restrictions but if you want to fly on a
plane then we're still going to have the
restrictions in place on wednesday biden
center for disease control prevention
announced that the federal
transportation mass mandate which has
been in place since 2020 will remain in
effect for at least two more weeks
um
cdc continues to monitor the spread of
the omicron variant uh blah blah blah
tsa will extend the security directive
and emergency amendment for 15 days
through may 3rd
they're still doing
i mean all you can do is laugh at this
point they're still doing the 15 days
thing
it's just hey guys it's just fit really
this time it's just 15 more days to slow
the spread and then you can and then
after two years and 15 more days
then you can finally take your mask off
on the plane
even though there was no reason to ever
be wearing one on a plane in the first
place
it's the one place where the mass
mandates remain in effect for everybody
and yet it's the one place where they
are the least needed
despite how it may feel despite what you
what you might think when you're because
you're on a plane you're 35 000 feet in
the air you're in this tin bucket
shooting through the sky
and uh you know you might think it's a
lot of like just recycled air that might
feel very dirty no but it's actually the
cleanest air you're likely to breathe is
in a plane thirty five thousand feet in
the air
the safest place to be in pretty much
every sense of the word
no reason to have masks at all
but just 15 more days they guys they
mean it this time
15 more and then we're done
maybe another 15 after that but
seriously after that we'll be good
i want to play this clip for you um
because i'm not i'm not done harping on
this dr oz running for senate in
in
pennsylvania as a republican i'm not
gonna be done harping on him before
until until the you know until the race
is over so he's running for senate as a
republican in pennsylvania he just got
the big endorsement
from
donald trump
trump who said not just hey you should
vote for this guy is the lesser of two
evils but actually that he's a great guy
he's a great leader he's pro-life he's
super conservative that's that's what
donald trump claimed
um
now we know that that oz historically
has been pro-abortion anti-gun there's
been leftists on pretty much everything
he was he not only endorsed the trans
kids phenomenon but he was one of the
early adopters of it
he was cutting edge right out of the
gate
or before even everyone else had come
out of the gate he was he was out there
promoting trans kids
and uh here's another clip that
resurfaced as they say
here's a dr oz
a little while after the jesse smilet
hoax talking about his good dear friend
jesse smallett
what men want is a new movie which
everyone is going to love and we're
going to talk about it in a second
but before i get to bed jesse smullet
who's been on the show who we all adore
uh was recently injured it's being
called a hate crime yeah i don't know if
you've been able to speak to him at all
i had well you know i had to check on my
baby exactly right
cash mate from empire good friend he is
resilient and
his mother raised him right he is just
at his very core he is love that's just
who he is and love is always going to
win
hank and tried the devil tried it but no
not this time but jose if you're
watching this the entire audience all of
us are saying we love you very much yes
yes
we love you jesse
just an admirable man great man we all
love justice millet
that right there is
uh the republican in pennsylvania who
got the donald trump endorsement great
stuff is always from dr oz all right
this is from 19th news says kentucky is
the first state where clinics abortion
clinics will be completely stopped from
providing abortions the state
legislature enacted a far-reaching
abortion law on wednesday with so many
restrictions including a 15-week ban the
clinic said they've been forced to stop
performing the procedure
the law known as house bill 3 takes
effect immediately
and the abortion industry in kentucky
they're you know they're distraught over
this and they're saying that they're
gonna
i mean there's staff cuts so many people
are gonna lose their jobs and their
livelihoods and of course uh what i say
to that is thank god
i there's there's there's nothing that
makes me happier than the thought of
people at abortion clinics workers in
the abortion industry losing their jobs
and their livelihoods
you absolutely deserve that
i hope you lose your job and your
livelihood and
what's more is i hope you suffer also
from losing it
for your own sake because first of all
because it's justice you deserve to
suffer but also um because maybe then
there will be some real
atonement on your part
um that's that's something that can come
from suffering
maybe in your suffering you'll be able
to reflect
on the
hideous evil you've been a part of
you've been you'll be able to reflect on
that and have a moment of awakening and
some real redemption that's that's my
hope for you
in your suffering which again you you so
deeply deserve um speaking of which
charles booker is a democrat running for
senate in the state and um he yesterday
posted this video of him talking to
women who were just distraught over all
this and he's giving them words of
encouragement let's listen to that
kentucky
will be
essentially the first state
when they override this veto
to effectively ban all abortion
they are making a decision
do they actually want to reduce abortion
help families or do they just want to
punish women
do they actually want kentuckians to be
safer
or do they want to just take advantage
of wedge issues at your expense
do they really care about the
commonwealth of kentucky
or do they just care about power that's
what they will be telling you today so
remember this day
and know that i'm going to be with you
every step of the way every step of the
way
thank y'all
you see the woman at the end there is
pretty distraught she's comforting
he's comforting the woman who's uh
just very upset that she wouldn't have
the opportunity maybe in kentucky to
murder her child anymore
um
you know what you have to understand
about men
especially there is no
creature
in the known universe more
pathetic
and gross and disgusting than uh than
the creature known as the pro-abortion
man
which which i would put as even as an
even an even more despicable character
than the pro-abortion woman even
and i say that because i actually
believe that you know i'm i'm uh
you know me i'm archaic and
old-fashioned i believe that men should
take leadership roles you know they men
should be leaders
and when it comes to protecting children
protecting the most vulnerable and
protecting women
especially
young women who are taken advantage of
and lied to by the abortion industry
like that's an area where men need to
take leadership and if they don't and
they fail
then uh yeah i think that they deserve
even the majority of the shame
especially because for them
you know the women who are sitting there
listening to a man advocate for abortion
well you do realize apparently i guess
you don't
that
the men who support abortion it's
because
it just makes their life a lot easier
they want to be able to use you
sexually
they want to
be able to the reason that they want the
quote bans off your body even though
there is no ban on your body the ban is
concerning the body of the child saying
that you can't kill the child
but the reason is because they want to
use your body
as an object
without having to worry about any
consequences like say a child being
conceived
and what's more um if the child is
conceived
they're very happy about the fact that
um
but you're gonna be the one to go
and do the dirty work of having the
child killed
so it's great for them
they get to use you sexually get
everything they want out of you
um
they avoid responsibility
because as weak cowardly men that's all
they care about is avoiding
responsibility
and uh the hard part is is
not does it concern them
they can they can wipe their hands of
the whole thing
so that's the story of pro-abortion men
all right one other thing here um
here's a good story from coindesk it
says a non-fungible token nft of twitter
founder jack dorsey's first ever tweet
could sell for just under two hundred
and eighty dollars which is still
two hundred eighty dollars too much
but the current owner of the nft listed
it for 48 million dollars last week
iranian-born crypto entrepreneur cena
estavi purchased the nft
of the tweet for i think we have it
there
yep that's so that's the tweet there
it's it's jack the first ever tweet and
he's saying just setting up my twitter
that's the tweet now
he purchased this tweet for three
million dollars
in march of last year and now he's
trying to sell it and he was offered 280
bucks for it
now
200 280 million dollars is uh you know
rather 2.9 million dollars almost three
million dollars
maybe just a slightly overpriced because
i can have that tweet for free
like i just i could take that tweet and
screenshot it and i you got it for three
million dollars i got it for nothing and
we both have exactly the same thing
which is an image of this tweet which is
not worth anything
i mean this this um
as i've been saying about nfts i think
this kind of drives the point home
um when when the when the value can
depreciate that quickly
it kind of shows you that nft's uh the
value for an entity is totally
artificial
these are as i've said it's they're
basically beanie babies digital bean
babies but a lot but but a lot more
worthless than beanie babies because at
least beanie babies are physical things
that you can take ownership and
possession of
and at least if i you know if i buy a
beanie baby
and there may be many that look like it
but i actually have this physical beanie
baby and no one else has it i have this
one
no one else has the exact same one
so
maybe i could take some comfort in that
at least
but if i have the digital image of a
beanie baby then anyone can have
exactly the same thing and it doesn't
even exist
so totally artificial value
it's based on nothing at all other than
just the whims of
people who are into buying nfts
and that's especially precarious in a
country where
the whims change so often
so because of the whims of nft
collectors
last year that tweet went for almost
three million
a year later they just said yeah you
know what i don't we don't feel like
pretending that that's worth anything
this time instead we're pretending that
this that these things are worth
something
not exactly the smartest investment
strategy i would say let's get now to
the comment section
[Music]
says i'm not a zoologist and yet i know
what an elephant is saying you're not a
biologist is the dumbest thing you can
say in an argument about gender well
it's credentialism on steroids
the idea that you have to be
credentialed to possess even
basic
knowledge about reality
now there is a there's a place for
credentialism like we talked about
planes
flying a passenger airline
i i think that you got to have some
credentials there
like if you're the if you're um
the captain of the plane you're the
pilot i want to know that you've got the
credentials you have not only experience
but you've gone through everything i
want to know that
but now we say that just to simply make
a statement about basic reality you have
to have degrees and everything and
you've got to have them all up on your
wall before just to give you permission
to say something like
you know men have penises
another comment says
where are we
i decided to take sweet daddy walsh's
alternative option and me be more
forgiving of the lebrance mistake the
first time i got screamed at by baby
killing fanatics i cried for hours
i liked their video and subscribed to
the channel no intention of actually
watching but little things helped and
prayed a rosary for them they aren't as
firm and based as they should be but if
we support them in prayer they could
develop the virtue to double down in
their defense of life
another comment about the same issue
that i read before responding
major tom fisher says matt when matt
walsh said that there were no comments
defending the pro-life youtubers it
immediately reminded me of something
i've noticed
entirely too few conservatives are
jumping into online conflicts to provide
support when someone openly makes a
conservative point and they're getting
shame for it we need to praise them in
the same comment sections people are
openly decrying them in we can't have
people openly supporting conservative
positions if the end result always ends
in mass hatred and loss of your platform
even if all you do is restate the points
the person is making or providing
minimal praise like so true or based we
can support people by saying the right
things by who are saying the right
things by making them feel like they're
not fighting alone yeah i totally agree
with that and that goes back to my point
of isolation where the left wants to
make you feel like you're you're
isolated you're the only one who feels
that way
and that isn't helped when as you point
out you know somebody
um
says the right thing makes a correct
point stands for the truth or whatever
and they're getting killed for it
and all the people who agree with them
are kind of standing silently off to the
side
or maybe hiding in the bushes somewhere
and like whispering putting their thumbs
up hey good job
that kind of thing
that doesn't help much
because they they still they're still
getting overwhelmed by all the hatred
and they're still going to feel isolated
the best thing you could do is actually
speak up and say hey i agree with this
person
provide a little bit of reinforcement
so um
i agree with you there and that did
occur to me as i'm as i'm scrolling
through twitter people responding to the
you know these youtubers who made the
pro-life video
and the fact that it was just all
negative
i didn't i didn't see one tweet
speaking up in support of these two
and you know what i would have
tried to remedy that in my own small way
by tweeting something in support of them
until i discovered
that they had apologized
and not only that but apparently the
woman not only apologizing but throwing
her husband on the bus
and saying oh i didn't edit it i didn't
know he's going to put that in there
that's even worse than the apology
so once you do that i i
i cannot support you
and defend you if you aren't going to
defend yourself
why should i take that on and and have
all the arrows pointed at me
when you're not even going to stand next
to me and you're the one this is you
were talking about
like i'm willing to stand next to you
and have and take take
and share in that and have have a
portion of the arrows pointed in my
direction but i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna have them pointed at me and then
you go scurry off
or even turn on me now and apologize
you know so so now it's like i'm
you're actually when you apologize and
you renounce whatever you said you're
joining the outrage mob
so you're not just leaving me alone to
the mob but you're joining them you're
adding to them
so no you can't do that
if you want to be supported and defended
you at least have to support and defend
yourself
if you're not willing to do that then
and th this is why i despise
the apologies so much
because for many reasons we've talked
about plenty of times but
the main thing that gets me about it is
that you are pulling the rug out from
underneath of your defenders
because how many times have we seen this
somebody says something
uh they're getting attacked for it but
then other people come
to their defense
and put them put themselves on the line
a little bit
you know put themselves they go out on a
limb
for you and they and they say you know
what i'm going to defend this person
but then you hop off the limb and leave
them there alone
it's uh
you can't do that and and once you do
that then
there's nothing left to defend because
you've given up
you know if there's one thing we could
be sure of it's that disney has
seriously screwed up this is what
happens when you when you alienate
parents and um you make parents feel
like you're standing on the opposite end
of them and you're trying to you know
indoctrinate your kids in fact when you
when you are open about it then people
kind of get upset and that's why the
daily wires investing 100 million
dollars into creating a platform for
children that's actually for children
and it's called dw kids we've hired the
veggietales writers to help create our
first two children shows chill a time
about a family of homeschool chinchillas
doodles with noodles that centers on a
man and his puppet giving drawing
lessons and over the next three years
we've committed to investing 100 million
dollars into children's entertainment
content and that's big news take it from
the number one lgbt children's author
in the world uh because in order to
change the culture you have to make the
culture and daily wire is making the
culture but the thing is we need your
help to do it so today you can head to
dailywire.com subscribe and use code
build the future for 45 off your
membership this offer ends today so you
got to subscribe right now now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know it feels always kind of cheap
and easy to use a segment from the view
as fodder for the daily cancellation and
it is definitely cheap and easy but
sometimes it's okay to go the cheap and
easy direction of life i think so we
turn now to the screeching banshees of
the view as they discuss mike pence and
his views on marriage during the q and a
his most recent yacht speech pence uh
addressed his support for so-called
traditional marriage otherwise known
simply as marriage uh but addressed it
in a relatively sort of circumspect way
let's watch that
if one of your children came out to you
as gay how would you respond what would
you tell them
i'd look them in the eye and tell them i
love you
i believe marriage was ordained by god
and instituted in the law
but we live in a pluralistic society
and the way we go forward
and the way we come together as a
country united
i believe is when we respect
your right to believe and my right to
believe what we believe
a political answer mostly meaningless
but i'm not going to harp on that you
know we actually aren't going to come
together as a country united simply by
respecting each other's right to believe
whatever we believe i mean we obviously
all have the right to believe what we
believe
you can't stop somebody from believing
something
even in like north korea you technically
have the right to believe whatever you
want to believe because no one can get
inside your mind and stop you from
believing
anything
um but
acknowledging that we all have the
ability to believe whatever we want to
believe is not itself the basis for any
sort of meaningful national unity
and though i do acknowledge other
people's right to believe whatever they
believe i certainly don't respect
the beliefs themselves necessarily
true national unity could be forged
through shared belief
not shared acknowledgment of everybody's
right to believe what they believe but
through actually sharing in the same
fundamental values and beliefs
not that everyone's marching lockstep
and believes all the exactly the same
things on every single point but having
some basic fundamental values and
beliefs in common
that's where you have unity
because then you're uniting around that
you take that away then what are you
uniting around there's nothing there
um i don't share the beliefs of the
other side in this country and i also
don't respect their beliefs and i find
their beliefs to be abhorrent insane and
disgusting so much so that i
actually don't even respect them
personally either
so that's that's the situation
in any case this is all somewhat beside
the point i suppose the heckling
heritage on the panel weren't discussing
that issue exactly instead they offered
their insights about the marriage issue
and um so we're gonna we're gonna go
through just a brief sampling of this
first up is the token fake conservative
that at the table um alyssa farah who
used to work for pence and here's what
she says and some of the other women
i still advise a number of republicans
um in one issue that i have two issues
i've told them across the board you will
lose the younger generation 35 and down
is if you do not come around on marriage
equality and climate change the
country's mind is made up i'm someone
who believes you can believe what you
want in your church i'm episcopalian i
have certain beliefs in my church but it
is the law of the land that you can
marry who you love and that is a good
thing having the right to choose who you
want to be and not being made to feel
shame
is what democracy is well like who
decided
that a traditional marriage is a man and
a woman who came up with this plan well
everything that exists in nature
right people say it's unnatural but
isn't everything that exists
by definition it is natural but is
homosexuality even mentioned in the
bible i don't think it is
your former boss and mike pence i i
think he's lying on that tape um and i i
think that you know words are
meaningless when your actions say
differently right and um let's just take
a look very briefly mike pence's record
with the lgbtq plus community
um in 2000 um he uh said during his
congressional campaign that congress
should oppose any effort to put gay and
lesbian relationships on an equal legal
status with heterosexual marriage
now i have to check so don't quote me on
this but i think that the clip you just
watched actually now holds the record as
in fact officially the dumbest 90
seconds in the history of television
there's a lot of competition for the
title but the sheer amount of dumb
packed into such a short period of time
creates an incredibly and perhaps
historically and maybe fatally potent
concentration of dumbness
so let's try to our best to kind of sort
through it all starting at the beginning
first the pretend conservative says that
she is still advising republicans now i
wish i could just assume that she's
lying about that but unfortunately i
have no doubt that um any number of
republicans would be foolish enough to
take political advice from a talking
head on the view now i could definitely
see somebody like adam kinsinger maybe
utah's governor spencer cox paying money
to hear the sage wisdom of joy behar's
tv sidekick
and the primary piece of wisdom she
offers to these poor dull-witted saps is
that the best way to win the young
generation is to give up defending
marriage in the family and to become a
climate change alarmist
she didn't say it there but i can
guarantee she would also advise that
republicans lay off the pro-life stuff
maybe start adopting some pro-crt
talking points take a friendliest
friendlier stance towards gender
ideology learn to love gun control
in fact i'm positive on that last point
because apparently during another
segment on the show she conceded that no
one needs an ar15 quote unquote
um another concession to impress young
people i suppose
but the problem is that you aren't going
to win the young over to your side or
anyone over to your side
by becoming a pale imitation
of your opponents
why would any young person go to the
republican party to get their
progressivism fix when they could just
go to the democrats and get the real
stuff pure grade right from the source
what are they going to choose organic
grass-fed leftism or watered-down
pre-packaged
leftism with artificial flavoring
next we hear from the other woman who
says that democracy is the right to
choose who you want to be without
feeling shame
no part of that is true or makes sense
you don't have the universal absolute
right to choose who you want to be
whatever that even means and you
certainly don't have the right to not
feel shame
now shame may be warranted or not the
person causing you to feel shame may be
justified or not depending on the
circumstances but whichever is the case
you can't claim from the universe the
right to be free from shame or judgment
or criticism
there's no government in the world that
can protect you from those aspects of
life
nor should the government try
speaking of the government none of this
has anything to do with democracy
democracy is a political system which
comes in various forms direct democracy
representative democracy and so on but
democracy is not the overarching
catch-all term that people seem to want
to turn it into
when somebody says democracy these days
what they really mean is
stuff that i like
whatever they like or want is democracy
whatever they don't like or don't want
is anti-democratic
which is totally nonsensical
then to top it all off she claims that
anything which can be found in nature is
natural now
this is technically true as the word
natural can be defined as existing in
nature but
just because something exists in nature
or can be found in nature that in and of
itself doesn't mean that it's good
cancer is natural in that sense it
exists in nature
cannibalism exists in nature murder
uh non-consensual sex happens all over
the animal kingdom
you're really walking down a precarious
path when you try to morally justify
something by pointing out that it occurs
in nature
you need to offer more than that
after all the whole reason the law
exists is that we are naturally inclined
to behave in immoral ways if we weren't
then there'd be no need for any law at
all
after that joy behar says that
homosexuality isn't in the bible
and she's right
about that
of course i mean aside from first
corinthians 6 leviticus 20 romans 1 26
1st timothy romans 1 27 numerous other
pastors but aside from all that it's not
in there
finally the other dim bulb at the table
gets a chance to chime in and begins by
pointing out that mike pence opposed gay
marriage in the year 2000
you know who else supposed gay marriage
in the year 2000
um barack obama
hillary clinton
the entire democratic party
the vast majority of the country and
nearly the entire world outside of this
country
like they all did too
at that time
this is actually a significant point
that she raises inadvertently you know
because it does bring to mind the fact
that just a couple of decades ago nearly
everyone everywhere believed that
marriage was between a man and a woman a
decade and a half later that view had
become not only unpopular but
unspeakable another five years after
that and nobody even knows what a man or
woman is anymore
might this be evidence of
i don't know a slippery slope
worth thinking about
that's a thought process that may be
beyond the capacities of the ladies of
the view because it is a thought process
that involves you know
thought so instead they just babble
nonsensically and that's why
as easy as it is to say i will still say
that today the view is canceled and
we'll leave it there thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor in chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode the
texas governor takes border security
into his own hands the midterm races you
should be watching and new jersey public
schools are set to begin teaching gender
identity to first graders join us to get
the facts first on the news you need to
know with our show morning wire